yep there hi we're here at South by
Southwest with the director of the
entertainment Technology Center drew
Davis hood drew how are you good how are
you think I'm good thanks so we were
talking before we went live about how
South by Southwest is really the
intersection of Technology and
entertainment and as the et see the
entertainment Technology Center you are
too yeah what's fun about South by
Southwest is it started as a music
festival first and grew from there to
film and then they had an interactive
and games and my gosh now there's edu
there's a vision to venture part there's
a green part of incumbents the range of
how media and technology can interface
with our culture at large and so that
that hybrid groups of people coming from
all over bring a certain energy that I
think very unique to the festival and it
really is accessible yeah this is my
first time here it definitely is and
you're on the board of South by
Southwest correct yes I got I'm on the
board for interactive I just happened
because he don't know I went to the
University Texas for my PhD and my
dissertation advisor knew the people who
were founding South myself interactive
and that led to being invited to help
judge a jury and i happen to be reliable
and that led to being invited to be on
the boards helped shape how interactive
covers the latest in terms of media and
interactivity around games just
location-based stuff film the are now of
course is hot i like right now this year
it seems like everybody's talking about
virtual reality and or artificial
intelligence it seems big two things
happening a lot around our stuff like
southwest so it's really exciting to be
just sort of keep my my finger on the
pulse of what's going on by being
involved with that and with that what
have you seen so far this year that
you're excited about well like i was
just saying right now the the
explorations in VR ranging from i was
just in the showcase for interactive
where i got to see some of the stuff
like a lot of music happening with
virtual reality so people could play
together even though they're
asynchronous and leading towards things
around artificial intelligence not only
things like your series in your lexus
and i know there's going to be even more
that seemed use going to cover
with Andrew more coming here into town
later but just how people starting to
look at how that applies throughout our
lives you know our daily lives in
general I think that's really exciting
to see the ways that it just enhances
what we can do is across our date yeah
and you know yesterday we met up with
some people a lot of gaming folks what's
that like to you know have a chance to
come down here have all of these you
know incredible people in the same two
block radius that's the for me the value
of something like any event where you go
public is yes you can do phone calls and
catch up but when you come to town and
you're able to just sit down and catch
up it's the people that make it
worthwhile so the panels and all that
are interesting shore but catching up
with your colleagues and networking is
really both in terms of me helping
understand what's going on but also
touching base about possible
collaborations returning ml
entertainment Technology Center or when
people are interested in recruiting our
students being able to talk more about
the program like having those one-on-one
conversations and then like that you can
get so much out of it talking to so many
people all in one moment across the
weekend or week well thank you so much
for taking the time to talk to us so
very welcome enjoy the rest of the week
thank you do